welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about that
incredibly embarrassing moment from your
childhood that no matter how many times
you were able to relive it will always
be embarrassing because it made you into
the super villain that you are
today my name is mt and i'm here with
off-screen producer brandon what's going
on brandon hello mt i'm doing great um
just keep calling me off screen producer
i know some people said we should change
it but please don't like i said
previously that is your first name
off-screen is the first name brandon
middle name last name barrick
there we go there we go i i was there
when his birth certificate was written
uh that's how that works it's very kind
of you
i don't carry around a long-form birth
certificate i just have mt to be like i
i was there i saw it well done because
your birth was a nexus event dude it's
true
it's true it branched the timeline what
a what a great segway mt what a great
segue mt
what if has been an incredible journey
so far about what could have been for so
many of our heroes and some of our
villains i've really enjoyed the show
and it's introduced all these new
characters uh and some brand new
concepts as well for example we now know
about absolute points which are moments
in a universe's timeline that cannot be
changed are altered no matter how bad
you want to get in there and mess things
up uh so that all that all leads us uh
to this week's big question
what are some absolute or nexus points
in the mcu okay okay okay that's a great
question brandon well let's first
establish what we mean when we're
talking about an absolute or nexus point
because in what if episode 4 we saw a
version of doctor strange that was using
the time stone to try and prevent the
accidental death of his love christine
palmer from mean girls a lot less mean
here get in the car dummies we're going
to change the timeline
[Laughter]
however no matter how hard he tried he
was never able to stop her from dying
the ancient one explained to stephen
that christine's death could not be
prevented because it was quote an
absolute point and absolute points
cannot be changed or altered because
doing so would greatly affect history in
that universe but she says if the other
strange succeeds in reversing an
absolute point in our universe the
resulting temporal paradox will destroy
this universe and this also shows that
absolute points can be specific to a
certain universe in our mcu universe
christine palmer doesn't die so that's
not an absolute point for us but in that
episode's universe that has to happen
for some reason now you may have also
noticed that we've referred to absolute
points as nexus points as well this is
because what if head writer ac bradley
said in an interview with the goat movie
podcast that had she written episode
four of what if after seeing the loki
series she would have called the
absolute point a nexus point instead the
what if episodes had to be written so
far in advance because of the technical
needs of animation so the nexus
terminology wasn't around yet so to
recap a nexus point or absolute point is
a moment in a universe timeline that is
so historically important that it cannot
be changed or altered because doing so
would create a temporal paradox that
destroys that universe and a nexus event
is something that can be changed and by
doing so creates a branch timeline and
we saw this in the loki series and it's
also important to remember that nexus
points can exist in a singular universe
or across multiple universes for example
tony stark's death seems to be a
constant across multiple universes as
eric pointed out in a video last week
and if you haven't seen that video be
sure to check it out because my man goes
in and sort of like goes into this weird
conspiracy because it kind of feels like
tony stark was meant to die ah
it's very weird the mcu picks characters
that they like to die and then makes it
makes us watch them die so many times
over and over and over again like vision
please stop i can't see another vision
go you know what this vision it let him
take over the entire multiverse because
we've already had enough missions die he
deserves it he deserves a win let him
live let vision live even though it's
ultron vision vision deserves to live
god damn it but enough for the preamble
let's dive into this week's big question
and see if we could figure out some
absolute or nexus points in our very own
marvel cinematic universe let's start
with a big one the snap three phases of
the mcu led to that ultimate moment of
population control that must be a nexus
point in our mcu in fact the tva didn't
even blink an eye when the avengers
totally messed with the timeline to undo
it all like even doctor strange viewed
14 million 605 different outcomes and
they all involved a battle with thanos
that led to the snap even if the snap
itself is just a nexus point in our
universe because what if has shown us
other timelines where thanos does not
perform the snap the collecting of all
the infinity stones for the purposes of
harnessing their powers is likely a
nexus point across universes something
that every serious universe conquering
baddie loves to do because why not if
there's six colorful
fruity pebbles someone's gotta have them
see one that's got to have them that's
that's obvious it's a nexus point it's
gotta happen in our timeline it's so
important and it looks like another time
it's on its way to happening too you
know we saw thanos you know zombie
thanos is collecting all the stones you
know the thanos that ultravision
slices of like deli meat he's going
after the stones you know that got me
thinking of even though it's sort of not
really related i kind of want a what if
episode of what if casey from the tva
decided to use the infinity stones at
his desk okay so if we're gonna talk
about nexus points mt which we're doing
right here we can't ignore
the number one nexus being in our hearts
in our minds and in our own timeline
jeff goldblum
oh jeff goldblum
oh it's called yes of course
yeah yeah yeah i think wanda maximoff
becoming the scarlet witch is definitely
an absolute point in the mcu timeline uh
and i got two good reasons why for that
one the existence of the scarlet witch
is prophesized in the darkhold uh in the
book of revelations the book of
revelations for evil evil people uh you
know and if you're working so hard with
dark magic you're gonna get a few things
right and he was right about the uh you
know catholic was right about there
being a scarlet witch so we get that and
when wanda first interacts with the mind
stone as we saw in one division she has
a vision of the scarlet witch you know
again another part of the prophecy so
like
wanda come becoming the scarlet witch i
mean it has to happen it's so important
and it's obviously going to play an
important role in
uh doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness maybe in spider-man no way home
who knows uh and we know you know we've
seen the scholar witches in other
universes and timelines totally
uh and it's possible that her coming to
power could be a nexus point across the
universe but i think she's definitely
like a nexus point in the mcu but hey
speaking of ultra powerful women i think
we should consider the creation of
captain marvel as a nexus point because
now okay could argue that the creation
of every hero that was involved in the
infinity war was crucial to the way that
things played out but i think that carol
danvers really stands out here because
of the immense scope of her power
because she like the scarlet witch was
powered up with the cosmic assistance of
an infinity stone and not only does she
work to keep earth safe but also the
entire universe as much as she can
anyway because she's only one woman
after all and who runs the universe
girls girls
[Music]
girls beyonce said queen bee queen bee
set at and as we've seen on what if
there are multiple universes in
timelines that rely on her to be an
equalizing force to incredible threats
you know like when she fought thor or
when nick fury was like hey captain
marvel check this out captain america is
still frozen
so yeah she's like very much a very
important uh weapon or defender a shield
for multiple universes totally i mean
maybe let her win one of these fights on
what if jesus i know jesus christ like
getting blown up well then again
i do not think that carol danvers died
from that explosion
yeah and also like sort of how he
remains sort of eluded and like the tva
sort of eluded in loki it seems like the
avengers are pretty much constants
throughout a lot of these universes and
the in the name of avengers comes from
carol danvers so like
for us to even have avengers carol
danvers has to have existed at some
point that's a great point and we've
also seen you know throughout the mcu as
we learn more about ancient powers and
you know super powerful beings so few of
them turn out to be good or outrageous
right
most of them have like horrible plans
you know even like odin who protects
midgard quote unquote uh for most of his
existence was an [ __ ]
he literally killed so many people he
was like and he basically got bored of
it or like tired and he was like oh i'm
tired of like beating up all these
people i'm gonna be nice now
and his daughter's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing he's like go to your room
go to your room
you're grounded and then he has other
kids and never tells him about him
he's not a good dad
yeah it's never like in these things we
meet this ancient being that's like oh
i'm super nice and awesome uh you know
we're going to meet the eternals who are
that but only to a point because like
most of the time they're like not my
problem
get a deviant involved and i'll show up
but otherwise
that's not my problem
it's yours
thanos not deviant enough he's too
handsome enough too
not our problem
sorry gotta sit back and have a family
um
you kind of brought this up a little bit
empty even so we'll go a little deeper
into it uh let's consider this next
absolute point or nexus point uh and
what has to do with nick fury okay it's
his idea to bring together a group of
remarkable people to see if they could
become something more was instrumental
to saving earth from all the impending
threats that we have faced and that
we're going to face in the very near
future i mean hey like nick fury said
you got to keep both eyes open
yeah yeah
surprise [ __ ] yeah and he
wouldn't he would never even have had
this idea if it weren't for carol
danvers i mean you know she gave him the
name the avengers right it was her call
sign right uh but because you know he
was just going around doing his business
working for shield and then she showed
up showed him like oh there's all these
extraterrestrial threats out there that
we need to be hyper aware of i need to
get a team together uh
it's so important and like i i don't
think you can stop it because even in
that what if episode three where we saw
all the main avengers get killed off he
still was like well i'm still gonna put
a team together it's gonna happen
i'm making my team goddammit and like
the number of times that nick fury has
almost dined or we thought he was dead
and it turns out he's still alive
you know you can't stop him in our
timeline he's unstoppable uh and no
matter what yeah yeah you can't if you
get rid of whoever his a team is he's
gonna have backups he's gonna have
backups to those backups and backups to
those backups those backups if you had
to you'd rip open a whole uh in the
whole meta universe and pull in dc
characters if you had to no you can't
you can't stop them 100 100 like
literally he would pull all my he would
pull in cecil from the invincible
universe first and they would be best
friends because those two [ __ ]
are just
they like to plot they like to plot for
the good of humanity
so yeah like nick fury putting together
a team of avengers that's a nexus point
you can't stop it's gone you cannot it's
gotta be
[Music]
that sign can't stop me because i can't
read but from the good we now look to
the evil well sometimes evil sometimes
good the god of mischief himself loki
because after the events of loki we
might be able to consider loki a nexus
being but one thing we definitely know
for sure is that loki attempting to
conquer asgard midgard slash wherever he
happens to be is a nexus point across
timelines and it's basically what the
whole loki series is about no matter the
timeline or the universe loki is
burdened with glorious purpose like the
glorious purpose to conquer and he
constantly feels underappreciated and
overlooked for a seat of power and when
you have a loki actually rebel and do
the right thing it shatters the entire
timeline it's like what what are you
doing tom hiddleston you're supposed to
be doing the shenanigans no shenanigans
what do you what you want to make out
with yourself what is going on
yeah it's crazy to think that he who
remains aka kang who could see
everything from the beginning of time to
the end of time and all the timelines in
between right even he knew that if there
were two loki's willing to work together
it would just destroy everything which
is crazy uh yeah
this is like i think you're right empty
this is a nexus point across all
universes your loki has to be willing to
conquer and desire to conquer and try to
conquer like you can't stop him uh not
at all yeah we saw gloria
yeah it's that glorious purpose he's
burning with it we saw that in one of
the one if's you know he showed up ready
to take earth let's go baby uh
what he's always gonna do he's always
gonna be trying to steal the throne of
asgard like that's his thing you can't
you can't stop it you can't undo it it's
gotta happen because i think it is so
important for every timeline that at
some point loki tries to do tries to
take over it's got to happen okay i got
another i got another bad guy for you mt
okay maybe if you don't agree with his
his plan i don't know uh the celestial
ego oh no he's fine he's a good guy he's
like he's a nice guy he's fine he's fine
he just didn't want to play child
support i mean you know you pay
little [ __ ]
who does if you if you have trillions of
kids who wants to pay for it i'm not
gonna pay for it make the government pay
for it he has no job ego is a deadbeat
he has no he can't pay child support get
back at it yeah
how's he going to get a job he's a whole
planet okay right no one's going to hire
a whole planet what to to be a barista i
don't think so yeah he's also very old
there's a lot of ageism out there you
know right
how's he supposed to get a job
uh but anyways you have ego you know him
ego growing from just like a floating
consciousness to a full-fledged living
planet like hell-bent on reshaping the
universe in his own image you know boom
that's a nexus point like because he is
like a celestial and they you know
they're from the beginning they they're
formed in the beginning of each universe
it's like i don't think there's any way
around him like he's always gonna be
created he's always gonna be there and
he's instrumental in creating peter
quill in each universe so it's like i
think he's a nexus point uh probably in
every universe but definitely in the mcu
he's the nexus point
you couldn't go back and stop ego from
forming because i think he is so
important and he destroys like whole
planets and stuff oh yeah there's
definitely always going to be an ego in
every universe and then we sort of see
that in what if but here's one that you
may have not even considered brandon
the awakening of the dark elf
malekith everyone's favorite mcu villain
everyone's always talking about malekith
and killmonger there's the race to
number one one
boom
two male kill monkeys yeah yeah every
little villain wants to grow up to be a
malikith everyone really loki that was
his main aspiration
to be the king of space and then
maliki but anyway when jane foster
accidentally came into contact with the
ether aka the reality stone it awoke
malaketh and the other dark elves from
their hibernation slumber and this also
happened during the convergence a cosmic
event where the nine realms are all
aligned and all of this led to the
chaotic events that we saw in thor the
dark world and as we've already sort of
discussed here there's always seemingly
someone going after these infinity
stones so with that in mind there is
always going to be someone disturbing
malachite slumber so that's why we think
that malekith's awakening in the dark
elf's awakening might be a nexus point
so someone's going to be disturbing
malikith
uh yeah and if it happens during the
convergence watch out guys because he's
he's pissed everything's about to get
dark hopefully he's got a night light he
wants the darkness he wants the doctor
he wants it uh once you go black brandon
i'm telling you don't you go black uh
you want to go back that's what valik is
doing
in his version perhaps
uh perhaps that is true yeah i we don't
we don't talk about malachithon he's
kind of forgotten unfortunately yeah
he's he's a real badass character on the
couch i love malikith as a character i
think that he's really
sort of he's honestly he's doing his own
avengers end game in thor the dark world
he just like hey something went wrong
and i just want to use the infinity
stones to fix it and so that's what he
did i love alec
yeah but it does make me think you know
if jane foster had never discovered the
ether during
uh
during the convergence and now that kind
of brought the reality still like back
onto the table right
right would thanos have been able to
even get the reality stone if those
whole events with jane foster hadn't
happened
would he be able to because we don't
know where they were where the ether was
right boar just kind of put it somewhere
right yeah and like that's actually a
good question and i think that
the reality stone might have been needed
to be gotten either last or second to
last because i think that the stones
have a ability to communicate with each
other and like there's this weird like
pull as we saw with uh vision and when
vision and wanda were hanging out or
like you know secretly making love uh i
think vision was like oh man like
something's coming like i feel my pimple
it's uh uh lord voldemort is near
my scar
he's coming we gotta go um no i no i
think that was when um thanos was coming
to wakanda to actually take it from
vision right you knew that he was there
yeah yeah yeah and so like i feel like
as long as thanos had like five stones
you could use the space stone to be like
all right and now here is the reality
stone yeah show me where it is yeah so i
think that he would have found it to you
eventually yeah okay so one of the most
important scientific discoveries within
the mcu occurred when hank pym
discovered what he would go on to call
pym particles very smart branding uh
yeah a very good businessman
no one can take your [ __ ] because i've
never met a pimp in my life so he's got
their particles they're my
without them he never would have been
able to develop the technology that led
to ant-man and wasp uh and that leads to
the discovery of the quantum realm uh
which they knew about but they couldn't
actually get to without those those
particles right and we've seen multiple
timelines and universes have an ant-man
so it's clear that the discovery of pym
particles uh cannot be prevented it's
really important in our timeline and
other timelines and universes we all
know how important pimp particles and
quantum technology was when it came to
the avengers stopping thanos
and undoing what he did create the
creation of pym particles is definitely
a nexus point like they need to exist
absolutely to give again to give like
the heroes like the advantage when it
comes to dealing with these cosmic
threats they're gonna be facing even if
you go back in time and you kill hank
pym when he's a baby which why would you
do that you're a monster
you're still going to have someone
figure it out someone's going to figure
out like pim part of who's you know
you'll get you'll get like you know
darren cross once he knew that they were
out there he tried to figure out and he
got pretty close
didn't quite get the mechanics right but
uh
someone someone's gonna got it
there and someone's gonna go after those
particles oh yeah for sure like those
are a huge part of the marvel cinematic
universe and like
honestly probably going to be the main
focus of quantum mania because
everyone's going to probably go crazy
over this quantum technology that saved
the universe and of course with sunny
birds mentioning that quantum of arms
race or the energy race i mean uh with
that is coming to the mcu i think that
quantomania is going to be that and
everyone's going to try to get their
hands on the pin particles especially um
hydra who stole that pin particle from
darren cross um in ant-man one they've
been working on the pin particle
technology all this time from like what
2014 to 2023 they're probably trying to
hack the secrets of the pin particle so
yeah this is a very big deal yeah i mean
i'll tell you mt i've been to disneyland
and they use those pin particles to make
regular sized meatballs huge it's crazy
is that how they do it that's how they
do it over there they uh
they have that's a secret sauce they
make pretzels big they make other things
small it's it's crazy what they're doing
that's how they make that disneyland the
small worlds ride yes
it was a normal size used to be big and
they shrunk it down shrunk we know the
disney secrets subscribe today for more
disney secrets that they won't tell you
from the vault fresh from the vault
anyway but also no but speaking of you
know pink pym and the pym particles we
also have to talk about the
disappearance of janet van dyne because
i definitely feel like that is 100 a
nexus flash absolute point and this
would eventually lead to the knowledge
of quantum tunneling that would make
time travel possible thus the events of
avengers end game because i don't think
scott lang would have really known much
about the whole quantum thing if janet
didn't say hey watch out scott uh don't
do that thing that is gonna really come
in handy in a couple of minutes for you
all right goodbye
listen scott i got this whole story
about the dangers of shrinking down too
small but i'm not going to tell it to
you right now
i'm about to die yeah i mean yeah these
this is you know that's a good point mt
like this nexus point is very close to
the discovery of pym particles you know
with that leads to the discovery of the
quantum realm but if like janet hadn't
accidentally
been shrunk down i mean she did it on
purpose it was an accident but like
if she hadn't have done an accidental
act of bravery right
she was doing this accidentally now she
was so brave during you know the missile
thing it was like i'm going to go down
even though i have a kid i got a family
and i'll never come back like i got to
do this to save everything right if she
doesn't do that and
if she went down and like came back and
was fine they might have been like okay
we'll never worry about it again but
because she goes down there and she gets
lost you know hank
he tightens up the grip on pin particles
keeps them out of the hands of everybody
for a long time uh and he also spends
time figuring out how to do it and how
to get down there safely and how to get
someone out of there if if that if she
had never been lost yeah he may have
just been like quantum realm's too
dangerous let's not with it you know
what's going on with our lives i think
no matter how you slice it she's going
to get stuck down there sorry janet you
got to
[Music]
yeah go in the zombie episode she gets
stuck down there so you know it's gonna
happen
uh it's just gotta happen sorry janet
sorry janet i feel bad about it she'll
fight for now beautiful woman but sorry
you gotta go sorry
but those are just some of the potential
nexus points that we think exist within
the marvel cinematic universe let us
know if you have any others in mind down
in the comments section below because
yes please love
seeing our lovely nerd babies say
beautiful things about the mcu uh but we
also say you're wrong you're wrong
you're dumb
you're
wrong i can't even believe you said that
but before we continue our merch
partners at epic hero shop have all
kinds of cool clothing and gear inspired
by your favorite properties and they
have a really cool shirt inspired by
venom let there be carnage that you need
to check out and they're also running
out of stock of the shang tree and the
what-if shirts so grab one or both of
those before they have retired to the
blue dungeon forever uh we're gonna
shove them into the disney vault
that's right we stole stuff and we're
putting stuff in yeah
so grabbing something from new
rockstarsmerch.com is an awesome way to
support the channel and to show the
world your love for your favorite fandom
and before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
people that help us bring big question
to you folks like honey we all shop
online and we've all seen that promo
code field taunt us at checkout well
thanks to honey manually searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past
because honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your card and honey supports over 30 000
stores online from tech and gaming to
popular fashion brands and even food
delivery and when you check out from one
of your favorite sites the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons wait a few seconds
as honey searches for coupons you can
find for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop producer zack recently used honey
to save 10 bucks on a baby shower gift
and honey has found its over 17 million
members over 2 billion dollars in
savings so if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out on free savings it's literally free
and installs in a few seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid in supporting this podcast and we
never recommend anything that we don't
use so get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
big question that is join honey dot com
big question now it is time for our bite
size questions and our first bite size
question of the day is brandon once you
turn to the dark side do your false
ghost privileges get revoked and this is
from iaj smith on discord thank you aj
smith
the dark side brendan what do you have i
ever told you the story of that
plagiarism
do it make your dreams come true
what are you waiting for
do it
i love a good star wars question so
let's dive into it okay
if you were born a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away you could possibly
wind up making a pretty big decision in
your life do you go to tashi station to
get some power converters which is what
i would do
homies toshi station power grid
um i was going to go to station
murders
here are the guys
shut the [ __ ] up you know what i've been
through with your acid in my house you
drinking my blue milk
messing up my moisture evaporators
talking to you outside i'm gonna i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go call that crazy
old uncle ben i'm gonna tell him get
your ass out of here
i'm about to adopt one of these jaws
take your job boy about these [ __ ]
jaws
we just made abusive uncle ben i mean
i'll win uncle owen you know every now i
mean uncle owen he paid the price for
helping out his family he did he's right
away jeez dude geez
did you say extra crispy recipe so
should you choose that sith path even
for
most of your adult force-wielding life
that doesn't preclude you from becoming
coming back as a force ghost at some
point wow just look at our main man
anakin okay he came back as a force
ghost at the end of return of the jedi
though yes he did go back to the light
side like right before he died a classic
move right before you died be like i'm
so sorry for all my sins
i'm turning
but it's still clear that even if that
with that last minute convergence he was
uh his privileges were not revoked he
was allowed to be a force wow he killed
all them kids in the school and the
force was like hey man at least you're
sorry and then the younglings [ __ ]
dumblings a whole tribe of sand people
just wiping them out those youngins were
ghosts we didn't see those youngest
ghosts they they weren't old enough to
learn how to do it it's true well empty
let's let's actually talk about let's
establish how you gain the ability to
come back as a force in the first place
okay normally when a force sensitive
being dies their spirit becomes one with
the totality of the force you just kind
of get evaporated into general forceness
you're gone but your spirit goes into
the the force ether okay
however a jedi can learn a technique
that allows them to deny the will of the
force it is the will of the force for
you to go into the main bank but you can
deny that will of the force and retain
your individual spirit separate from the
overall force then you can if you do
that you can remain as like kind of a
misty force spirit that's just kind of
floating around or you can manifest
yourself as like a translucent blue
version of yourself uh like we had
as if you were alive now this is what we
saw in the films right these are the
force ghosts we saw in the films and
sometimes the ability to return as a
force ghost is tied to a final act of
selflessness just before your death like
the fact that we see anakin as a force
goes at the end of return of the giant
it's because he saved his son his son
was getting
the shocker
and he was like my boy baby boy
he throws the emperor over the edge
that final act of selflessness you know
helped him to become a force ghost the
the concept of force ghost has existed
for a long time in the history of star
wars but in modern film
story canon what we know as
just from the movies it was it hadn't
been done in a while and it was
rediscovered by qui-gon jinn uh remember
him he got he got done dirty in the
phantom menace it was an act of
selflessness that helped him after he
dies he's kind of just like floating
around as a spirit and then he's able to
manifest himself into a force ghost
again and so he then teaches that
technique to
uh to obi-wan and then yoda who on their
own then learn how to do it themselves i
think he teaches it to yoda first in the
clone wars series yeah
yoda teaches it to obi-wan yeah he also
likes speak it's weird
it's so hard empty with all the like
star wars stuff because it's like
some of it's in conroy some of it's in
like legends canon some of it's in like
the books that they consider part of the
movie it's very confusing it's basically
religion yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
my retelling of force goes it's there's
a lot to it and if you're very
interested i invite you to look into it
because there's the main movie canon and
then there's like legends canon which
was all the old expanded universe stuff
so there's a lot of ways to approach
this but for from what i can understand
in like the modern film canon no one had
done it for a while until qui-gon came
around he figures that he's he's taught
it by somebody according to
some legends canon but also
because he lived a life where he kept
his individual self separate from the
force he was able to do that great jedi
yeah because part of part of becoming a
force ghost is like retaining your sense
of self along with a balance of the
force because the problem with modern
jedi was they were like you got to be
all in on the force there is no self but
as qui-gon knew it's like you got to
have a little sense of self uh separate
from the force and that's how they're
able to do it um but what about the sith
that was the question right
[Applause]
well they actually have their own
technique called essence transfer or
transfer life where they can bind their
souls to inanimate objects or other
bodies like sometimes a sith would like
bind his soul to an object in his tomb
to kind of like haunt his tomb in case
anyone came around
or an emperor palpatine's case he kept
transferring his life to clone bodies to
keep himself alive for long periods of
time talk science
cloning
as for a straight up just like a
straight-up force ghost legends cannon
is full of sith horse ghosts there are a
ton of them in legends canon so it's
clear that the ability to become a force
ghost is not tied to following the light
or the dark side it's more about
retaining your sense of individuality
and self when becoming one with the
force at the time of death so why we
haven't really seen a straight sith
force ghost in the movies like the main
canon that everyone knows they can do it
it's possible
i like that and but i i'll also
particularly like what you talked about
with essence transfer or the transfer
life thing that the seth can do because
one of my favorite dark side users and
this is in the comics is a dark side
user by the name of darth moment and fun
fact in the current canon darth moment
was it was the dark side user that
actually made darth vader's castle and
they've specifically made it on mustafar
because mustafar is this planet that has
like a has a huge concentration of the
dark side and so i mean it looks like it
it doesn't look like a fun paradise it's
very dark sidey and what's interesting
about darth maul is that darth vader
reactivated him because he was um
originally a mask
and like once like people started
wearing the mask he's like all right
darth malman is back i'm back in
business baby he's sort of like
transferred his essence in that way
through that object so i really hope
that they bring in darth momen for
mandalorian season three because
those two like mando versus momen come
on come on disney you know you want to
it's so good sorry anyway that's my
spiel i love it darth well brandon i got
another question for you ready for this
i'm ready i'm ready how long do you
think it takes for all of the mcu heroes
to put on their costumes this is from
tyler edwards on discord thank you
discord and shout out to everybody on
discord we love all of you
thank you for the wonderful questions
you know it's it's really tough to say
how long it would take each mcu hero to
get their outfit assembled but i do like
this question a lot and it made me
wonder
instead of like how long each one takes
who takes the longest to get ready you
know what i mean
who are they waiting for you know they
got the quinn jet running they're
sitting there like come on guys we gotta
get out of here uh
so we went ahead and we compiled a list
of the heroes to see if we could figure
it out okay so right let's start off
with the big one okay in the early days
i think tony stark would definitely take
the longest right oh yeah that was a
cumbersome yeah he had a fully
mechanized system or robotic arms and
he's got to put the suit on and things
have to be screwed in and even with all
the help it seemed like it took forever
his outfit was like so cumbersome
uh that every time he made a new suit
one of the main features was how fast he
could put it on right oh he had a
briefcade suit and he's got the suit
where the pieces flying towards him uh
and he worked it all the way up to
nanotechnology that he probably learned
from shuri and wakanda i mean they cut
that part out but plagiarism we clearly
saw like oh what's this quick ass way to
put on a suit pretty so that means
anyone with access to like nano
technology whether it be shuri's or tony
starks they're getting dressed really
quick so that's iron man rescue
spider-man war machine black panther and
probably even sam with his like wakandan
made captain america wingsu oh
i mean the cow probably takes like the
longest to get it over here but like if
anything needs to be nanotech it's the
freaking cowl of that thing good god so
then like anyone else with like access
to alien technology is probably getting
dressed pretty quickly so that's like
captain marvel uh all the guardians of
the galaxy i mean drax only wears pants
so that's like pretty fast i mean he has
sensitive nipples
[Music]
yeah he's got sensitive animals but we
can't really blame drax for that i mean
you can't blame him but he could get a
shirt without nipple covers on it or
something oh
yeah you're right just like nipple holes
yeah that makes sense and if you if
you're peter quail you know you got to
put on the shirt in the pants but like
you know the the head thing just comes
on
there's a lot of nanotech there let's
think about anyone with magic abilities
that can use their powers to suit up
quickly so doctor strange scarlet witch
wong you know they could probably do a
little magic spell and change their
outfit very easy and of course like thor
he can change his outfit with a bolt of
lightning so as long as as long as he's
outside he can get dressed really quick
um hulk just has to hulk out that's very
fast that doesn't take long so now let's
think about like all the earthbound
terrans not utilizing technology so
steve rogers and bucky are both super
soldiers so they probably don't take too
long right because they're they're fast
they can move fast they're strong i mean
bucky just tears a
sleeve off he's ready to go
pretty much yeah cap was in the military
he knows how to get dressed quickly
don't have a lot of time natasha and
clint they're also highly trained
soldiers so they get dressed quickly and
then we got like this new hero shanghi
right that he's got the mystical magical
dragon scale armor from tallow but it
still looks like it functions like
normal clothes i don't think it goes on
quickly or anything so that leaves us
with who i think takes the longest to
get dressed to get suited up to get
ready for battle
and that's ant-man okay i agree with you
he's got that bulky suit that's like
it's like coveralls like full coveralls
uh it probably takes him a minute to put
it on because he's scotland he's goofing
around he's making jokes uh and you have
to make sure that it's on properly like
fully sealed up because if it's not
sealed and you shrink down you're going
to die because you can't breathe
yeah you want to take an extra second to
make sure okay this is all clean and
even by the time we get to infinity war
and he has like the helmet that kind of
is like nanotech i feel i think the rest
of his suit is not nano it's still that
kind of suit that uh hank pym made i
know it changes from the first ant-man
to the second ant-man but it's still
kind of a bulky
suit to slide into hope van dyne has
like a similar suit but she she gets
dressed way faster than scott does like
sky oh yeah he's [ __ ] around he's
taking too long and i don't know if he
counts as a hero but 2016 red guardian
trying to fit into his old suit
takes longer than anybody i mean
ridiculous
ridiculous hey it still fits still [ __ ]
that's all that matters my friend it
still fits i i 100 agree with you on
ant-man because in ant-man 1 when hank
goes to save scott in prison those ads
gave him 10 seconds to put that suit on
and i was like that is there was no
way possible that
paul rudd would be able to put the suit
on in 10 seconds
not just paul rob anyone i couldn't do
it in like 10 minutes it would not
happen so like good guys i don't know mt
i'm a scared little boy and if you put
me in a prison cell and said you have 10
seconds to get dressed and you'll get
out of here i would do it real fast
oh yes
thank you but now it is time for our
favorite part of the show it's time for
the box of scraps ooh boxes crap
now brandon what is the nexus point in
your life what would you consider a
nexus point for you oh okay i i got a
good answer for this mt okay there was a
point where if i were to invent a time
machine and try and go back and change
it all this is the point i could not
change okay it happened in kindergarten
uh a young a young brandon had been cast
uh in the holiday production called the
littlest christmas tree uh that whole
day that our kindergarten was gonna do
you know this was gonna be my chance i
was cast as the titular littlest
christmas tree oh dang yeah
let me see them imdb credits right i
know check check my star meter uh
but
you know i was gonna be the starter show
i knew on my lines i knew everybody
lines cause i was ready to go i was
ready to be a star you know it's gonna
happen
not not long before we were set to to
debut our one and only performance of
the littlest christmas tree at the
christmas pageant um
i was recast okay i uh
oh [ __ ] oh that's so wack yeah because i
knew everyone's lines they cast me as
santa claus
uh and moved another kid into like the
littlest christmas tree position i don't
know why i don't know why they did this
to me mt wow because santa in this
production doesn't come in until the
very end and he's kind of like the day
of this machina he the story is very
similar to
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer where he
has to come in santa has to come in and
tell all the other trees to be nice to
the littlest christmas tree it's it's
very simple
and because i'm playing santa i gotta
look the part right so they give me a
little santa suit with the big beard and
they shove a pillow up under the suit so
i'm fat and i'm a little kindergartner
so of course it looks hilarious it's the
night of the show i'm very excited you
know i'm sitting backstage i'm waiting
for my big moment i get my q i come out
i'm ready i'm ready to give like a
brando s performance just really blow
these people away
okay and they laugh they laugh at me
empty
oh because of the suit because i look
ridiculous
but you know in my mind i'm nailing it i
am santa claus yeah i am i'm santa claus
incarnate why are they laughing at santa
do they know who i am right
this is drama this is art yeah but i'm a
professional
so i do my lines i finish the part i go
off stage i'm devastated i'm just
devastated because i'm like they just
they didn't get it they didn't get it
but what i didn't know mt was at that
moment i didn't realize
what how profound that moment was to me
because when i looked back on it i was
what i did enjoy was like getting the
reaction getting the laugh yeah it gave
me that taste it gave me a
and ever since i've been addicted to it
you know i've been chasing that dragon
i've been chasing the laugh
so that's that's the nexus point in my
life if that hadn't happened i wouldn't
have you know pursued what i pursued in
my life i don't think you could you
can't change that moment it's it's very
important to me uh and it has affected
me throughout my life
that is an amazing story i was hooked
and honestly screw those people for
laughing at you even though they were
supposed to i mean they were all right
really we should blame my teacher for
letting me going out looking so
ridiculous seriously and you didn't even
sign up for that role you were no i was
supposed to be on rose christmas tree
robbed you know what
we'll find another production of the
littlest christmas tree i'm going to
restage it this year
and we'll put you in that costume we'll
make it fit yeah
but no that's a really good one like
though i think uh a nexus point in my
life actually um happened like around
like
2015-ish always 20-15-26 no 2015. i was
going into a newbery comics with my
girlfriend at the time and like i at
that point i just never read comics at
all i was just like all right newberry
comics it's like you know we'll buy
socks or like whatever they sell here
but then like i was looking at the comic
section even though like that's not
really all that like emphasizing
newberry comics these days and i picked
up a copy of spider-gwen and like me not
knowing who spider-gwen is like whoa
this is super cool like this is like i
just love the cover this is really
awesome and so i buy the copy of spider
gwen and i go me and my girlfriend go
home and like i'm reading this i'm like
oh my god
comic books are awesome and then like i
just you know i just got it i was like
yo i really want to go back to newbury
comics to pick up another comic and so
the next day i go there and i buy a
bunch of comics and then from there my
love of comics sort of just dominoed and
i here i am now that's beautiful do this
here and so like yeah i literally did
not get into comics until 2015ish so
hey this kind of happened to go into
that store that day
i just happened to go to the store and i
picked it up i was like yo comic books
are awesome and like obviously i was
watching the marvel movies so like i
sort of had an appreciation for marvel
sure like i didn't know anything until
that moment so that never watches didn't
know that's a great issue it's a great
reminder folks support your local
neighborhood comic book shops seriously
go to your local neighborhood
neighborhood comic book shops because
like they need you to keep yeah they'd
love to have you they'd love to give you
some recommendations uh whether you
asked for them or not no i'm just
kidding but
there's always there's always helpful
people there who would love to get you
into a comic book or seven so uh check
them out for sure yeah seriously check
them out and comic books are literally
just a new like a different medium than
like you know movies or audio it's just
like a different way to experience
stories so if you're hesitant on reading
comics
take that out of your brain because like
literally they're adapting all the best
stories from comic books these days so
get into it that's a commercial for
comic books anyway
but that is it for this episode of big
question i of course want to thank my
good friend off-screen producer brandon
for joining me this episode please
follow him at grindenberric on twitter
you can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] most importantly follow at
new rockstars on twitter and also here
on youtube and when you do when you're
on youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications whenever we upload new
videos and also be sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to buy some new cool
shirts for you and your mom thank you
guys for watching and we will see you
guys next time goodbye bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]